One dimension in motion is not enough for us.
We need 2 dimensions or even 3 dimensions.
We need vectors.
If you know about vectors directly, skip to the quiz.
If you don't, stay with me.
Vectors can be represented by arrows.
Typically, we denote vectors by lowercase Latin characters
with an arrow on top of them,
and we can also express them in numbers.
This arrow vector is 4 units to the right
and 3 units up,
which is why we can write 4, 3 in this way.
These are called components of the vector -- x-component, y-component
if the x-axis points right, and the y-axis points up,
Let's look at a second vector.
If you call this vector B, that would be 2, 1
x-component 1, y-component 2.
Let's have a third vector that's called C,
and C should be 1, -3.
C goes right by 1 unit and goes down
by 3 units.
And now we can do some basic arithmetics.
We can add vectors, for instance.
Let's add B and C.
If we want to add B and C, we put them together.
The tail of C goes to the tip of B or the other way around,
and the resulting vector, which is B + C
goes from the tail of B to the tip of C.
So this is the sum of the vectors --
B + C -- and if you look closely,
you'll see this is 1, 2, 3 units to the right --
and this one is canceled with that one --
and 2 units down.
So what we actually could've computed is
the x-component of B plus the x-component of C -- 3 --
and the y-component of B plus the y-component of C makes 2.
That's the sum of vectors.
You simply add the components,
and geometrically, you chain these arrows.
And there's a second operation we can do.
We can multiply vectors with numbers.
For instance, if I want to multiply this vector B
by 3/2, I get an arrow in the same direction,
but with 50% more length.
I can do that in components, of course, as well.
So what I get is 3/2 times 2 and 3/2 times 1,
which is 3 and downstairs 1.5.
Obviously, 3 units to the right,
1.5 units up.
If you do this multiplication with negative numbers,
we are going to invert the direction of the arrow.
So if I compute, say, -1/2B,
I get an arrow of the opposite direction and 1/2 the length.
and components -1/2 * 2 = -1,
-1/2 * 1 = -1/2.
So this goes 1 unit to the left
and 1/2 unit down.
If you remember the NumPy package in Python,
this vector addition and vector multiplication
and the NumPy package in Python
this addition and this type of multiplication is already included.
The third operation that we can apply to all vectors,
is determining their lengths.
I'm writing it like that with double bars.
To determine the length, you can simply use
the Pythagorean Theorem.
One leg of this right triangle is 4 units long.
The other leg is 3 units long,
which means that the hypotenuse is
4² + 3² square root units long,
which means 16 + 9, 25 square root, 5 units.